i want to bring out my next guest you
know from the daily show
he's got some hilarious specials on
comedy central
he's the first comedian that i ever met
uh please welcome roy wood jr
hello moses thank you for thank you for
being here man that's my flula accent
that's the best i could do
hey thank you man thank you for having
me this is crazy where we are it's a
full circle moment when
you're honestly the first comedian i
ever met is maybe 2009 we were making
online youtube videos together and here
we are
again oh years later yeah
with the homie dave yeah yeah okay
okay yeah i'm thinking oh la la yeah
2000
yeah ben it's yeah it's been a minute oh
my god
it's old yeah it's weird where we are
but we're kind of essentially
every comic is becoming a youtuber yeah
that's what i'm learning i'm i'm getting
to that place now ordering mics
and super cool sound proofing equipment
to help my career it's like oh god yeah
a lot of the sound proofing stuff i'm
ordering is just so like my girlfriend
doesn't hear
how embarrassing online stand up is yeah
there's something to it
where even with the emojis coming up
and people like clapping or whatever i
still feel like i'm bombing i don't know
how you guys do
the online shows i tried a couple early
in quarantine
and i just knew immediately i don't have
the performance shot it's a special
talent
to come through somebody's phone yeah
you gotta bring it and my comedy doesn't
bring it physically
it's not expressive it's just i'm the
guy sitting in the corner complaining if
you pay
attention you might learn something but
that doesn't come through on a phone
the things that you told me back in 2009
are things i still carry with me today
like oh that's going to do and i'm glad
it was decent everybody so i'm glad i
wasn't a bitter angry soul who just told
you to go get a job and go to college
i'm sorry we don't need another white
guy talking about triscuits
but but that's the thing i want to bring
up is that you wrote an article
in in vulture essentially of the future
of comedy
and it talked about essentially the
lowest man on the totem pole
of how everyone kind of moves down a run
if you're playing arenas you're not
going to be playing comedy clubs
and anyone that was getting this the
biggest venues will open last
so the comics who play the biggest
venues will play the venue
the next size down essentially
which forces everybody below them down a
rung which cuts your money which means
you need to figure out another way
to make money and i think yeah i think
guys are figuring out like just
for perspective um what's the guy
terry fader for tor i'm not sure how to
pronounce his last i think it's fader
plays in vegas has a regular residency
in vegas
he's doing like comedy clubs right now
until the vegas venues open up
so you know he's gonna sell tickets and
the comedy clubs have to book the best
acts because they're trying to keep
their lights on so it's nothing i didn't
say that
in a way to hate on comics i'm just
saying that's how the industry is going
to have to survive
no i mean that's what has to happen god
bless the big wigs for coming back to
the clubs for a little while to keep the
clubs open
yeah you know i think it's a good thing
no i think a hundred percent i mean if
anything it prepared me because i am
exactly the person you're talking about
where i'm
the lowest man in the totem pole where
you're you're just headlining you're
just starting to fill rooms and then
everything is
completely come true everything that you
wrote down in the article and this is
this is really early march when people
are like this will probably be over in
may
it's all coming true now so i wonder
what do you see
now so now that was what four or five
months ago
do you see any is there any future
tallies you have now
here's the thing like everybody thinks
about comedy as
this these big name acts coming through
but
like honestly the average comedy club 30
weeks
out of the year it's road dogs that are
helping keep the lights on
it's the tuesday through thursday shows
those are the shows that help keep the
club profitable
um on the weekends or whatever yeah i
think that those guys i think you have
to start creating your own stages you
have to start
because here's what i think you got a
bunch of restaurants that are [ __ ]
because they can't get as many people in
as they want or
people are scared so you got to have
something to attract them so it might be
a symbiotic relationship you know
the thing is just the the bigger issue
right now but i didn't feel like i
accounted for
was the massive amount of unemployment
yes
entertainers we are disposable
income activity so even if the clubs are
opening back up how many people have 20
to 30 dollars to spend and that's not
counting all the people surviving like
everybody counts covered in deaths
but the people who survive [ __ ] they
got medical bills out to ask
right how many people are going to be
able to go out and just have a night out
like on a date night at a comedy club
that's a 80
spin 20 on tickets 21 drinks is 40 ahead
as someone who hates this and is a very
vested interest it is a waste of money
to be in a club especially when there's
so many great netflix specials
people on twitch there's people on
youtube doing this same thing or
something higher quality that you could
stay home
so why go out and spend money on two
drinks a whole plate of food risk your
life
then the and then the odd chance that
the comedians is good
do you think that so chris rock had a
quote years ago where he said that
everything that i do is to bring people
to my live show anything he did within
his portfolio
was to sell a 70 or eight whatever his
ticket cost is
to get someone to see him live do you
think it's the flip now
where if you do the live show for free
you do the live show at a cheaper rate
you do it in a park or a drive-in or
whatever wacky place the next year holds
for us
at 30 capacity do you think the live
show
is the new conduit to drive people
online
where you can monetize through
advertisements via your podcast
if you have a web series or whatever the
[ __ ] else you're doing
i honestly i think you're looking ahead
yes i do think yes that is but i think a
lot of comedians have not understood
that yet
i think a lot of them are very bullish i
think there's a lot
of there's a lot of people within our
craft that are
very dismissive of
technology they're very dismissive of
the evolution of how people consume
information and at the end of the day
you can be the purest so
i stand on the stage i'm old school okay
but you got to go wherever people are
and how people are
taking in stuff i honestly think that
chappelle has changed how the hour
special
will be constructed if you look at the
turn time from
shoot like the average hour special is
probably
shot eight months before it airs right
and that window is getting shorter and
shorter because
public attention spans are shorter than
the new cycle changes you write a joke
in april that's not even relevant in
[ __ ] august
by the time it airs yeah like yvonne
orgy i think had a
she shot her hbo special in february
and i think it aired mother's day so
that's maybe three months
from shoot to air that's an incredibly
short runway
and then chappelle did 836 which i would
argue
two months total working on some of that
material but so much of it was about
george floyd and so close to it
above maybe three weeks from conception
to air so does that mean that the
special gets less special when people
are not putting ten years of work into a
special like i was just about to take my
special right before the shutdown that's
like 10 years of work
so now you're thinking are you looking
at just a comic that's on the right for
six months that's the special
comes out immediately i think you have
to tap into right now
people are more connected to emotions
than laughs
and i think chappelle should work
because he touched people's emotions
and so i don't think it makes a special
any less special
it just has to be more in the moment and
right now our moments change
faster than they did under the previous
comedy construction timeline the
assembly line has to be shorter now so
you can still have an hour special but
if you have a special i give you a
perfect example so
i was like 40
i had about 40 percent of my next hour
done
when covet hit okay with the plan of
taping in november so
around march i had about 20 25 minutes
i went this is good this is for sure
will work there's probably four or five
minutes of that material
that i would even want to spew now
because just
tonally no like i had a whole thing
about congressional hearings and how
[ __ ] the concept of a congressional
hit nobody wants to hear about that
good luck getting anyone to care about
any of that stuff but in january
yeah that was the thing and it was
always a thing and it happened
like i hadn't it's crazy to think that i
have jokes about mass shootings and the
whole concept
of how and where they occur and how the
coverage is
how the media covers mass shootings that
even that
is yeah yeah do you even want to talk
about that right now
because even when a mass shooting
happens it doesn't even get the coverage
that it got pre-covered
because there's just something more
ominous and then you don't know who the
[ __ ] is going to win in november
which is also going to change the tone
of the country so
you do a lot of political humor how do
you feel about that yeah do you feel
about doing another four years of
essentially
trump jokes i mean with the daily show
it's all encouraged it's what you cover
so where do you feel like that is if if
trump wins again
do you have it in you to just be like
what else could you make fun of
i don't know if you can make fun of it
anymore
because it just keeps getting more and
more serious it's like the vice just
keeps getting tighter and tighter and
tighter
i think the last time i righteously
laughed at trump was when he looked at
the silver eclipse
i think yeah that was the last one he
looks into the sun
yeah yeah and like like the day after
that he's like all right get them kids
in the cages
i don't i don't know man i know that
at the end of the day it's my job as a
correspondent to put a face to the
people that are
struggling and dealing with a lot of bs
in the country and find a joke in that
so
i'll have to keep doing that but you
know you take a deep breath and do your
job
i would prefer that that's not the
situation
come wednesday morning in november but
you know we'll see
are there things that that maybe comic
should be doing so obviously investing
in themselves
those things are should not be doing
have you seen things of like
don't go live every day no one needs to
hear your thoughts
i wouldn't say don't go live every day
but if you're gonna go live every day
create an archive yeah like i don't
understand why people go on ig live
every day and you don't save these shits
like you like if i don't watch it live
like you have the audacity to promote
yourself as a
live appointment viewing with no option
for me to binge it later when all we are
as a society
habitually is a binge consumption
audience now yeah what do you think
you're the [ __ ] you think you're
11 o'clock news where if i just miss you
i miss you
no you're doing a chair with a laptop
you're spitting funny stuff but save it
so that people can find it later or
chop it down the snippets i just think
that
you're you're in a space now where
everybody's equal
nobody's better than you i've seen some
of the greatest comics on earth with
some of the shittiest framing and
lighting then there's zoom chats
so you could easily create
create the content that you want to be
hired to make
like just start doing that and if you
don't know how find somebody else that's
hungry
team up like this is the this is the
time to do that
man yeah to invest yourself and you say
team up get as close
to other people as possible so that
you're pushing trying to get in there
you have to be able to create on a
regular basis and have
you know some level of an agenda and
specificity
all this broad like when you talk to ron
in a second
ron functions has probably done it
better than most man
because cause ron is not trying to let's
talk about everything
no [ __ ] i like wrestling yeah let's
discuss it
and i think specificity is the new bra
so
find out figure out what it is you're
passionate about
and i think if you lock in on that type
of stuff and you know
then i think you're in a space where you
find something that speaks to a very
specific group of people and then that's
how you build your audience man
so that when the streets open back up
again and there is a cure and we're
having sex with no condoms
you don't have to bang donkey style
anymore to reduce the spread
donkey style it'll be good times yeah
well you know that's what they said
you're supposed to have such a doggy
style during college oh so you don't
face each other but at that point it
seems like
some other transactions if you're doing
it right if it's not a crime
you've been face to face at some point i
think at this point during covet i think
we should all agree that the glory hole
was ahead of the curve
out of the car i'm not sure if this is
the type of podcast to have that
discussion
but yeah i think it's a fair observation
at this point
yes it's very safe it's
it's very consenting there's a hole it
seems like the person on the other end
has the most control
to really fight anything off you don't
have these limbs yeah because limbs
attack i think a lot of these comedians
wouldn't get in trouble if they didn't
have
limbs i would do a comedy bubble though
go to orlando for that
there's no way there's no way i would do
a comedy bubble
i you know what i would only do a comedy
bubble with comedians
that are either married or have children
uh-huh
so not me you know and i'm serious like
when i look at the when i look at the
lineups of comedians
that are doing outdoor shows in new york
and the rooftops and in the parks
most of them 35 and under no kids
total like they're in a totally
different set of responsibilities a
totally different set
of people that they have to answer to so
you can be young and wow
yeah i'm 41 and i got two people living
in this house that i gotta answer to
you know i'm not going to leave her to
raise him alone so
not in exchange for working out a school
shooting joke
that you both know isn't going to be
relevant anymore
not in the week no it is something's
wrong with my life where i'm free to go
yell at people in the park
that's really all it is it's not like a
show you're just on the same level and
you're ruining it someone's day in the
park you know who's fun to watch you do
outdoor shows
it's uh mark norman oh yeah norman
mark norman if you go on his youtube
channel
he's probably got about eight or nine
different shows he's done over the
course of the quarantine he did one on
the sidewalk to passers-by
he did a drive-in he did a
in the rain you did the club yeah mike
went out so
yeah everybody was in their car no he
couldn't even hear the laughs it was
just people flashing lights
like he's probably done every possible
discipline
of outdoor show but mark is also a
wordsmith he's an addict like
he really is like seinfeld in that
regard but he really is doing it for the
love of the craft yeah
i don't even know if it's for the people
watching i think it's really just for
him
but i couldn't do that
i would love to but no i mean you got a
whole life
yeah the only other thing that i am
starting to scale back now
um i'm not gonna deactivate it but i
think i'm going to leave twitter
for a while okay i follow a lot of these
people
for the sake of being in tune with what
the streets are saying about a lot of
relevant issues right
when you consume bad news every day
and then you consume people's outrage
about the bad news
it's starting it's starting to [ __ ] with
me a little
is that maybe advice that comics should
take and that don't take the twitter
world who
you know you go on stage a lot of people
don't even know the person that got
canceled that day
that maybe just for your own psyche to
be a human being in this time and not
just
be like oh yeah since i can't be on
stage i'll just tweet 24 7.
i mean if it works for you everybody's
got a different joke machine
you know twitter used to be a good place
for me to run premises
yeah but
the more delicate the topic the more
nuanced the conversation and twitter is
not a place for nuance
so you know if i really want to explore
what people think about
a topic before i write a joke on it i'll
take it to facebook
because you get deeper answers and you
get more counter
it can turn into a cluster just of
argument but
it's people making great points in more
longer form
to help influence my analysis of the
topic but
i tweet here and there i don't tweet a
lot about politics because if i got
something funny to say about politics
i'm gonna pitch that
on the show and either i'm gonna say it
or trevor's gonna say it
so i'm not gonna burn those jokes on
twitter so why am i here what am i doing
and i mean instagram is cool
here and there but that's even worse
because it's an algorithm so now i'm
seeing the same 40 people
it's an algorithm and it's super sad now
and they're like what are you posting
about no one's vacationing so it's very
hard to find an excuse to
post a photo of your bot because it's
not like a beautiful background it's
like oh
there's your blinds again which goes
back to my point about how specificity
is the new broad because
everybody is talking about the news of
the day
yeah but do you have something deeper
that connects with people on a
deeper level that old andre three
thousand thousand let's talk about time
travel and rhyme javelin something mind
unraveling like that
where are the deeper conversations
happening and they're not happening on
twitter
no that's great advice i mean thank you
for going over that with us
specificity yes the new broad find your
own audience
you just gotta find something you're
passionate about man all right man well
thank you brother i'm gonna go
check on my child okay he hasn't you got
a real life burn something thank you so
much
daily show it's back you have great
specials out yeah
father figure and no one loves you there
wherever you go to bootleg content
it's there i'm not gonna find it yeah
okay find it
do the work google my name roy jr
everyone
thank you